die 28 jährige larissa hat die
zweiwöchige ausbildung an der
polizeiakademie berlin erfolgreich
beendet heute ist ihr erster tag auf
streife mit einem erfahrenen kollegen
als erstes hat junge gesetzes hüterin
einen neuen serien tun für den
streifenwagen heruntergeladen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja also ich sag mal so ein polizei zu
sein ist auf jeden fall mein absoluter
traumjob ja noch superstar topmodel und
nagelstudio aber beinahe schon wieder
mal die mindestens hauptschule larissa
land die vielseitigen aufgaben eines
polizeibeamten im streifendienst kennen
ich mache da bekommt man von hingucken
ein eps zwischen anfang gemacht dass der
großen spaß mit menschen zu arbeiten und
diese menschen dann an zu zeigen macht
auf dem fahrrad hast du kein auto und
warum hast du den komischen heim auf das
ist von uncool
wissen sie was dafür sprechen verwarnung
aus eine million euro erreicht ich mit
den jungen mann
hier schreibt die chance schreiben und
stolz behandelt die frischgebackene
polizist in ihrem ersten arbeitstag bei
der berliner polizei
wir arbeiten nur ausländer und doofe
frage würde man einen doofen eine
geladene waffe anvertrauen bestimmt
nicht unschuldig gleich heute schon doch
auch nichts
das mädchen schwere 17 uhr 2 ich geh
nach hause gesandt
[Applaus]